في الثالث من ماي الحالي مسيرات تستهدف
قلب الكرملين عمليه تركت اسئله كثيره
مفتوحه
اليوم تكشفت على ما يبدو ملامح عمليه
تشكلت ونفذت دون علم الرئيس الاوكراني
فمن واشنطن المتهمه ايضا من موسكو بالوقوف
وراء العمليه رجح مسؤولون امريكيون ان
الاوكرانيين هم النفذوا الهجوم وفق صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز
ووفق الصحيفه ايضا فان تقييما اوليا توصلت
اليه الاستخبارات الامريكيه عبر اعتراض
اتصالات يشير الى ان الهجوم دبرته على
الارجح احدى الوحدات العسكريه او
الاستخباراتيه الاوكرانيه الخاصه
هجوم دفع بالمسؤولين الامريكيين للاعتقاد
لا يوقع على جميع العمليات السريه كما انه
من غير الواضح اذا ما كان على علم بها قبل
تنفيذها
وبحسب الصحيفه يبدو ان الهجوم جزء من
سلسله عمليات سريه ازعجت مسؤولين في
امريكا اكبر مصدر لسلاح الى اوكرانيا
موسكو اكدت ما جاءت به نيويورك تايمز اما
فقد جددت نفيها معتبره ان روسيا تلعب على
مخاوف الغرب لتقليص امدادات الاسلحه
الاكييف
بتزامن مع ذلك كشفت الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه عن قائمه اهداف لمواطنين الروس
والرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الهدف رقم
واحد
قائمه اعتبرها لكريملين ارهابيه مؤكدا ان
الاجهزه الامنيه الروسيه تعرف وظيفتها وما
تفعله لحمايه بوتين
قائمه اهداف لم تخفيها تفتح اسئله كثيره
لعل من بينها ان كان لا يعلم عنها ايضا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات